[Music]
all right tonight more incontrovertible
evidence that deep state actors are
doing everything within their power to
damage unseat a duly elected president
that being President Trump and what's
worse is that the partisan press is
cheering them on and they are using this
league to bludgeon the president
politically not surprisingly members of
the deep state they ran to their
favorite liberal media outlet the
Washington posed with their latest
targeted leak meant to smear the
president here's the post headline Trump
national security advisers warned him do
not congratulate Vladimir Putin and he
did it anyway well it turns out that the
Washington Post reporting's contains a
bunch of fake news shocking Fox News is
reporting that a senior administration
official is saying that it is likely the
president Trump never saw the memo that
contained the warning about Putin
because he was briefed about his
conversation with the Russian president
over the phone but just like always
getting the facts right doesn't matter
to the destroyed Trump media they
cranked up their phony feigned outrage
machine let's take a look at that it's
not just what President Trump said
during that phone call with Vladimir
Putin it is also what he did not say
that has some in his own party angry
this morning this would be like J Edgar
Hoover as the director of the FBI
calling Al Capone to congratulate him on
a bank robbery is it going too far to
say that the White House is failing
America on the world stage President
Trump went out of his way to praise
Putin and not bring up extraordinarily
important and controversial topics it's
just the latest in what is obviously a
long pattern of behavior by this
president the president often
congratulate leaders who are not
democratically elected he often gives
autocratic and dictators a
congratulation donald trump not the
first president to make a mistake about
Vladimir Putin the other ones changed
their course we'll see if he ever can
another deep state actor former CIA
director John Brennan he is continuing
his baseless attacks on President Trump
now take a look how Brennan floats this
conspiracy theory take a look I think
he's afraid of the President of Russia
why well no
I think one could speculate as to why
that the Russians may have something on
him personally that they could always
roll out and make his life more
difficult clearly I think it's important
for us to be able to improve relations
with Russia but the fact that he has has
had this fawning attitude toward mr.
Putin has not said anything negative
about him
I think continues to you know say to me
that he does have something to fear all
right isn't John Brennan the guy let's
see he voted for a communist for
President of the United States back in
the 70s he's supposed to be nonpartisan
by the way how did he ever become the
CIA director now in reality he's nothing
more than an Obama deep state stooge and
Brennan also recently tweeted out this
threat to President Trump when the full
extent of your banality and moral
turpitude and political corruption
becomes known you will take your
rightful place as a disgraced demagogue
in the dustbin of history so you may
scapegoat Andy McCabe but you will not
destroy America America will triumph
over you Andy McCabe got fired because
the FBI recommend he'd be fired that the
the Inspector General report recommended
the same it wasn't Donald Trump and
that's the type of comment that now
shows why a whopping 74% of you the
American people are now saying that you
think this group of unelected
bureaucrats deep state operatives are
secretly trying to manipulate policy and
opinion in this country so it's more
apparent than ever the people like
Brennan and clapper and the rest of them
they're not even trying to hide their
abuse and their bias against President
Trump they want him out of office
regardless of what he does or doesn't do
a president Trump like he always does
he's fighting back he tweeted out quote
I call President Putin of Russia to
congratulate him on his election victory
Oh
in the past Obama called them also and
the fake news media's praised because
they wanted me to excoriate him they are
wrong getting along with Russia and
others is a good thing not a bad thing
and he continues they can help solve
problems with North Korea Syria Ukraine
Isis Iran and even the coming arms race
now Bush tried to get along he didn't
have the smarts Obama and Clinton they
tried but they didn't have the energy or
chemistry remember the reset and then
ends with Ronald Reagan's phrase peace
through strength now the media's
number-one objective is to take down
this president we pointed out every
night and we know that the deep state
knows this they're trying to exploit
this they're trying to indoctrinate the
American people remember at the
beginning of this administration
remember 125 deep state leaks and only
126 days the goal here is obvious but
the media is never going to tell you
that now just like they're not going to
tell you that back in 2012 interesting
President Barack Obama he did the same
thing congratulating Putin that now the
media's excoriating President Trump or
you cannot make this stuff up that is
how hypocritical the media the left-wing
in this country are take a look at this
Obama White House press release release
it reads in part quote President Obama
called Russian president-elect and Prime
Minister Putin to congratulate him on
his recent victory in the Russian
presidential election that's the same
thing that Trump did where's the outrage
where's the media condemnation this is
all one big massive hypocritical double
standard that's on display and sadly we
see it every day and the media is
whipping themselves into a frenzy acting
like this is a major massive national
security crisis it's not and by the way
since the media won't tell you about the
facts as it relates to President Obama
on Russia will give them to you remember
Obama and Hillary Clinton's this
embarrassing idiotic so-called Russian
reset there she is presenting it to her
counterpart by the way it was a photo-op
and a bad one at that and it
accomplished nothing then of course you
had Obama on the hot mic
whispering to Dmitry Medvedev he said
toe Vladimir I'll have more flexibility
after the election more flexibility
after will show you the tape
i transmit to vladimir oh how'd that
work out for Obama now in 2014 as a
history lesson
congressman Devin newness of the house
Intel committee he issued an explicit
warning to President Obama the Russians
are coming and want to influence our
elections and the Putin wants to create
chaos in the United States and around
the world so what did Obama do
absolutely nothing instead of keeping an
eye on Russia Obama mocked then
candidate Trump in 2016
say it's ridiculous to think that anyone
could rig an election no serious person
would ever say that or believe that and
then he said stop whining remember this
there is no serious person out there who
would suggest somehow that you could
even you could even rig America's
elections in part because they're so
decentralized and the numbers of votes
involved there's no evidence that that
has happened in the past or that there
are instances in which that will happen
this time
and so I divide mr. Trump to stop whinin
and go try to make his case to get votes
you know what it doesn't get any more
pompous or arrogant than that and
according to a new book Obama's own
national security adviser Susan Rice
remember she is he issued the stand-down
order to national security officials
that were coming up with options do they
wanted to counter Russia's attempt at
election interference well that's just
the simple truth Obama was warned in
2014 and did nothing said it could never
happen
stop whining the media is not going to
report that they'd rather attack
president Trump for something that Obama
had already done he's responsible for
2016 not president Trump and by the way
who paid for that dossier that was
Hillary now you're being lied to and
this is the sad part on a daily basis by
the destroy Trump media and those in the
deep State this is on a scale and a
level we have never seen in the history
of this country
now also tonight constitutional Harvard
Law Professor
Dershowitz he's agreeing with President
Trump that the special counsel should
never have been appointed he couldn't be
more right let's take a look first of
all presidents 100% right that never
should have been the appointment of a
special counsel here there was no
probable cause at that point to believe
that crimes had been committed I've seen
no evidence to suggest that crimes have
been committed by the President as I
said from day one there should have been
a special investigative Commission
nonpartisan appointed by Congress with
subpoena power to look into the role of
Russia and trying to influence American
elections and to try to do something
about preventing it in the future
instead of starting out with
finger-pointing and trying to
criminalize political differences behind
the closed doors of a grand jury that's
gotten us nowhere
presidents absolutely right this
investigation never should have begun
now we'll be speaking with Alan
Dershowitz in just a few minutes now in
addition to those comments while
professor Dershowitz is also out with a
brand-new op-ed where he writes in part
in this case the appointment of a
special counsel has done more harm than
good it has politicized our justice
system beyond repair and then Dershowitz
adds the public has lost faith in the
leadership of the Justice Department and
the FBI they do not trust congressional
investigative committees they don't know
whom to believe when they hear
conflicting accounts and there are leaks
galore followed by denials of leaks it's
a total mess and what do we have to show
for it just a handful of low-level
indictments based largely on alleged
crimes that are either totally unrelated
or only marginally related to Russia's
attempt to influence the presidential
election in 2016
professors a hundred percent right now
Muller is way beyond his mandate this is
what we call investigative creep the
entire investigation remember it was
supposed to be about Trump Russia
collusion it doesn't exist and it's now
turned into a witch hunt now what what
does professor Dershowitz get for
telling the truth about the special
counsel ah the answer is of course to be
attacked by fake news CNN let's take a
look as soon as I saw that tweet this
morning from the president quoting Alan
Dershowitz I said to myself I wonder if
the
it's going to invite alan dershowitz to
join his legal team it's kind of amazing
that he hasn't already maybe he has
maybe alan dershowitz decline i will ask
him but it comes in at the end of it's a
big high-profile situation knowing alan
dershowitz
knowing the President of the United
States I suspect he may be joining the
legal very commentary from a guy named
wolf that's what happens when your dad
or for a dissenting opinion that goes
against the destroy Trump media's Trump
Russia collusion conspiracy theory and
no evidence and it's been 14 16 months
also brand new tonight a group of
Congressman Matt gates Jim Jordan Mark
Meadows Andy Biggs they are demanding
that the report that led to the
disgraced former FBI director deputy
director Andrew McCabe and his firing be
made public now the Congress may want
you the American people they want to be
transparent they want you to know the
specific reasons for why McCabe was
shown the door because they're arguing
rightly so that what he did could have
put this country in danger now late you
remember on Friday night McCabe was
fired at 9:59 just before I went off the
air why for lying to investigators and
leaking to the media and lying under
oath even though the evidence is
abundantly clear why McCabe was fired
the media they somehow tried to blame it
on President Trump he had nothing to do
with it and the FBI director Chris
Wright he's now shooting down all of
these liberal media lies let's take a
look at what he's saying about McCabe's
firing I want to be careful about what I
can say about the process but I will
tell you that my commitment to making
sure that our process is followed that
it relies on objective input and that
most importantly it is not based on
political or partisan influence is
something I am utterly unyielding on